doesn't give you an excuse to run listen
yeah
Central we've got a 12f
the dark and color looks like uh
Mercedes
I-95 northbound approaching uh US1
[Applause]
he's leaving it out of traffic here he's
probably less than a quarter mile out
from US-1
all right he's getting back on 95 90
Central notified Flagler County
Texas
now he turned around right before me
cartridge is wrong with them it's uh 12
f for now we're not going to pursue with
the helicopter follow it
all right we're over 100 he's overtaken
Vehicles we're still in northbound
Denver
we're about a mile out from Old Dixie
all right he's getting off at Old Dixie
getting up Old Dixie at 95.
all right I'll use the signal forward
into the grass
rear bumpers ripped off it's driving
through the grass he's coming eastbound
on Old Dixie
I already wanted to set up for sticks
US1
and the county line
yeah Walter borderman rear bumpers
Hanging On by a thread he's dragging his
rear bumper
coming out some traffic a little signal
pouring into vehicles uh he's continuing
East on Walter Boardman past High Bridge
all right we're at John Anderson now
stand by
all right he's going to be eastbound on
Moody
just lost the rear bumper uh still
westbound on Moody all right he's
slowing down he sees the units ahead of
him it's kind of stationary standby
if you stop westbound all right driver
is getting out hands up looks like he's
uh giving up blackmail black hoodie
black beanie Black Panther
yep he's not 100 just uh east of uh
all right unit seats behind you guys are
passing turn back around
he's laid out thrown in the roadway here
all right
on the westbound side
right in front of that SUV
if you're like
roller
get up on one knee all right look I got
it broken okay I'm not looking at your
head get up on one knee roll over
then help yourself
absolutely have a seat sit with Thor
yeah you're under arrest
sit down Okay then if you gotta warm I'm
asking do I have a coupon
I don't know who you are how do we know
if you got a warrant man I'm asking you
do I have a warrant I fled because I
thought I had a child support one what
the fuck that doesn't give you an excuse
to run listen
yeah
it gives me an excuse to run if I got it
good job what
okay